What is our EMF waves less harmful than x-rays?
Well, most certainly, I would say, yes.
So, EMFs are electromagnetic frequency,
x-rays are also electromagnetic frequency,
so x-ray are extremely damaging to the tissue.
But, of course, you have to weigh all that out.
So, if I have x-rays that you have to do for my teeth,
what's the rad dose of those x-rays,
but not very high?
So, I could probably do, I don't know,
52 x-rays equivalent to one chest x-ray.
Chest x-rays typically, which you compare things to,
because as far as an x-ray itself,
a plane, let's call the plane view x-ray,
which is the old days when you took a x-ray,
you had a physical x-ray in front of you,
well, we don't see that so much, we see it's all digital,
but it would always compare to a chest x-ray,
because it's about a radiation that was needed
for a chest x-ray.
Well, if you have to go and get two x-rays,
I don't know how many two x-rays are gonna equivalent
rad dose of a chest x-ray.
Compare that to a PET scan or a CT scan.
So, let's have to do a CT scan in my lumbar spine
because I hurt my mac really bad.
But CT scan is equivalent to about 50 chest x-rays.
So, again, it's the rad dose of the radiation
that you're concerned with.
And yeah, EMF radiation is bad too.
So, if I'm using my cell phone
and I got it up to my head all the time,
talking like this, I never recommend that.
You know, that EMF's are going right through your head.
It's the constant use of it.
So, what's the rad dose over time is really the question.
So, yeah, there's a different issue there.